your um how do you define conservatism
maybe in the way you were thinking about
it yesterday what to you are
some principles of conservatism
let me define it and then we can we can
get into principles if if you want when
i when i talk about political
conservatism i'm talking about uh a
political standpoint that
regards the recovery elaboration and
restoration of
tradition as the key to maintaining a
nation and strengthening it through time
okay so this is something
that if you have time to talk about it
like we do on the show it's worth
emphasizing that conservatism
uh is is not like liberalism or marxism
liberalism and marxism are both
uh kind of universal theories and they
claim to be able to tell you
what's good for human beings at all
times in all places
and conservatism is a little bit
different because it's going to carry
different values
uh in every nation in every tribe you
know even every family you can say has
uh somewhat different values and the the
these loyalty groups they compete with
one another
that's the way human beings work so it's
deeply rooted in history of that
particular area of land well i wouldn't
necessarily say land you're right that
many forms of conservatism are tied to a
particular place so how does the
implementation of conservatism to you
differ
from the ideal of conservatism the
implementations you've seen of political
conservatism in the united states and
the rest of the world just to give some
context
because uh it's a loaded term like most
political terms
so when people think about conservative
in the united states they think about
the republican party
what can you kind of disambiguate some
of this what are we supposed to think
yeah that's a really important question
um usually the word conservative is
associated with
uh edmund burke and with the
uh with the the english common law
tradition
uh going back you know centuries and
centuries there's kind of a classical
english conservative tradition
that goes
uh fortescue hooker
uh coke selden
hale burke
blackstone before burke
if you take that kind of as a as a as a
benchmark and you compare it then you
can compare it to things like uh the
american federalist party at the time of
the the american founding is in many
respects very much
very much in keeping with that tradition
um
as you go forward
there's uh inc in increasing mix of
liberalism into conservatism and i think
i i think by the time you get to the
1960s
with uh
william buckley and frank meyer you know
the the jargon term is fusionism by the
time you get there
um
it's it's arguable that their
conservatism isn't very conservative
anymore that it's kind of a uh
a public liberalism mixed with a private
conservatism
so a lot of the debate that we have
today about you know what does the word
conservatism actually mean a lot of the
confusion comes from that comes from the
fact that um that on on the one hand we
have people use use the term i think
properly historically to refer to this
this common law tradition of which burke
was a spokesman
but but there are lots of other people
who when they say conservative they just
mean liberal
uh and um
i i think that that's a big problem i
mean it it's a it's a problem just to
have an intelligent debate as difficult
when
uh when people are using the the the
word almost in too antithetical what
would you say the essential idea of
conservatism is time you mentioned your
father is a physicist so a lot of
physicists when they form models of the
universe
they don't consider time
so everything is
dealt with instantaneously a particle is
represented fully by its current state
velocity and position
you're saying
so you're arguing
um with all of physics and and your
father as we always do uh that their
time matters
uh in conservatives that's the
fundamental element is the full history
matters and you cannot separate the
individual from the history from the
roots that they come from the parallel
in political theory
is uh is what's called rationalism
i guess we'll probably talk about that
some rationalism is kind of an
instantaneous timeless thing before i
mentioned that
liberalism and various enlightenment
theories
they don't include time at all their
goal is to
say look there's such a thing as
universal human reason
all human beings if they're reason
properly will come to the same
conclusions
if that's true then it removes
the time consideration it removes
tradition and context because
everywhere where you are at any time you
ought to be able to use reason
and come to the same conclusions about
politics or morals so that's a that's a
theory like uh
emmanuel kant or
john locke as an example hobbes is an
example
that kind of political theorizing
really does say
at a given instant we can
know pretty much everything that we need
to know at least the big things
uh and conservatism is the opposite it's
a it's a it's a traditionalist view
exactly as you say that
that says that history is crucial
you